- Thanks to Trade Coffee for
keeping Legal Eagle in the air,
'cause you would not want to see me
before my first cup of Joe. Am I right?
Courage Gallegos asks,
are you a Sith Lord?
Wouldn't you like to know?
(playful music)
Hey, Legal Eagles.
It's time to celebrate actually,
because just a little while ago,
this channel crossed a million subscribers
and roughly at the same time,
it crossed a hundred
years million video views.
I'm absolutely floored.
I can't believe that this
channel that was started
as a hobby, just because
I got mad at the TV
when people were getting the
law wrong on TV and movies
has expanded into a channel where
a million of you have signed up
to hear more about the law
and to learn more about
how to think like a lawyer
the laws that surround us every day.
So from the bottom of my
heart, thank you so much.
It's been an honor and a
pleasure to create this channel,
and I'm so honored that so
many of you have decided
to come along for the ride.
And since I can't throw a big
party where I can invite all
of you for various incredibly
obvious reasons right now,
I thought the best way
that we could celebrate
is to celebrate all of you guys,
because I couldn't have
done this without you.
So I asked for the questions
that you might have
about Legal Eagle the
channel, about me personally,
or about life in general.
So let's answer some of those questions
and talk about just what it
is you guys want to know.
The first question is from Nate Myers,
who asks "in what ways
has your YouTube channel
affected your job, your life in general?"
As if there's any distinction
between my life and my job,
those are definitely one in the same.
So in terms of how the YouTube
channel has affected the job,
not all that much, actually,
day to day practicing law.
The fact that I have a YouTube channel
doesn't really change very much.
Sometimes I get recognized,
but usually not at all.
And frankly, the main way
that the YouTube channel
has affected my professional life is that
it just takes a huge amount of time
to be able to do these videos.
I think that every video,
if we're talking about a
substantive legal issue
takes roughly 10 to 20 hours
to research and outline,
another one to four hours to shoot,
and then another 10 to 20 hours to edit
and review and edit again
and go back and forth.
Now I'm not doing the
video editing anymore,
but still that's a huge amount
of time to sort of go back
and supervise and, and that sort of stuff.
So for better or worse,
the YouTube channel is
starting to crowd out
my professional, legal and business life.
So that's definitely
something I have to take into
consideration, but it's
something that I absolutely love.
I have the best job in the
world to have this channel
and to be able to make creative videos.
I mean, semi creative, they're
about the law after all,
but to be able to make these videos
as part of my professional life
is just the best thing in the world.
And it's a lot of hard work,
but it's also incredibly
fulfilling and satisfying as well.
Kieran O'Sullivan asks
"Does the fact that most
criminal cases are settled
with plea deals bother you,
given the power imbalance
between the defendant and state?"
I'd say yes and no.
There's always going to be
a power imbalance between
the government, the state, and the people,
especially individuals
and especially people who
tend to be in lower
socioeconomic conditions.
I think that we can and often
have done things that help
make it a little bit more fair.
Under the Gideon case,
all criminal defendants
are entitled to representation.
That's what public
defenders are there for.
I think that public
defenders do a great service
to individuals and to the country
and they should receive more funding.
And the fact that things are often settled
through plea deals is not
necessarily the worst thing.
We don't want to have to spend
huge amounts of resources
on criminal trials every
time there is an accusation
of criminal conduct, obviously
there are going to be times
when people take a plea deal because
it's the expedient thing to do
or because they're not willing
to fight it out in court,
but often that's just
a more efficient way.
People are going to get less
of a criminal sentence through
a plea deal than they would
if they took things to court.
So no system is perfect.
Certainly the American
criminal justice system
is far from perfect,
but to the extent that there is injustice,
it's up to all of us to make it better.
And we certainly can.
There's a lot of things that we can do,
and we've talked about
that on this channel.
There's a lot that we can and I think will
be done in the future.
The MovieSquad asks, "have
you ever received criticism
from other lawyers for
hosting a YouTube channel?"
Well, first of all, I have
so many lawyer friends
and they're all very
supportive of the channel,
and a few people have expressed
to me that Legal Eagle
is the channel that they
wish they had started.
So ha, beat you to it.
That being said in real life,
the support is pretty unanimous,
and for the most part,
I think people recognize
that I am trying to explain
fairly uncontroversial
legal issues in the news
and that legal literacy is something that,
for better or worse, a lot of people need.
That being said, online, I
have received lots of criticism
from political pundits,
from other attorneys
who may or may not have
done their research,
and from a lot of people who
claim to be attorneys online.
I am a little suspicious
of a lot of those comments
that claim to have done the research
or have studied this
topic for dozens of years.
But yeah, for the most
part, I think the criticism
is generally well-meaning or
just incredibly misinformed.
Michaela P asks, "who is
the we at Legal Eagle?
How big is the team in the background?"
So I am so, so lucky to
have a few individuals
who help me out every day and frankly,
where this channel is
now would not be possible
without the people that I work with.
I have two main video
editors, Amy and Chris,
who do a fantastic job, and
often on insane deadlines.
I am constantly amazed at
how quickly Chris and Amy
can turn out some of
these videos and frankly,
how polished everything is.
If you see the 2D graphics
that are on the screen
and they'll fly in and fly out,
or the full screen graphics,
I have no idea how to do that.
That's all motion graphics
that's done in Adobe After Effects.
I can edit together a video if I need to,
but I am totally incapable of
doing what Amy and Chris do.
I just simply give them comments
and tell them that I want more of this
(angelic music)
or less of that,
(mumbling incoherently)
and they make it happen.
In addition to that, I work
with two amazing attorneys,
Andrea and Rob, who often do a
huge amount of legal research
when there is a topic where I'm
not a subject matter expert.
For example, the video I
did on Posse Comitatus,
that is not a law that I deal
with on an everyday basis.
And there's like one guy who
has ever done any research
on that particular topic.
Often I need help with
some of the research,
and Andrea and Rob are incredibly amazing
when it comes to helping out
with actually researching
these sometimes very arcane
and archaic laws that,
because of the times that we live in,
somehow rear their ugly head
and we have to figure out
what's going to happen and
what the legal confines are
of the various situations
that we deal with.
I also work with some amazing animators,
Alex and Nick, who are
responsible largely for
the animated series "The Case Of"
that deals with various
true crime related things.
So that's the lion's share of the team
over here at Legal Eagle.
I'm hoping to expand.
I'm hoping to be able to do more videos,
which may require that
the team get even larger.
Definitely would not
be possible by myself,
and I'm so indebted to having
such an incredible team,
and I'm looking forward
to working with them
in the future on this.
Asha'man Rich asks
"everyone out here asking
hard hitting questions, and
I'm interested in one thing,
pineapple on pizza, yay or nay, and why?"
Wow, man. I mean, that is a
hard hitting question too.
I do enjoy a pizza with
pineapple on it on occasion.
I would say I much prefer
generally speaking,
a Neapolitan pizza with added onions.
I'm a onion on pizza guy,
but there's definitely
a time and a place for
a pizza with a little
sweetness added to it.
Got no problem with that.
All right, Nik Hunder asks
"sometimes you have to
represent the bad guy in a case.
In those situations,
how do you stay neutral
in order to best represent your client?"
So I actually sort of
disagree with the premise
of this particular question.
A lot of my career has been spent in
the civil side of things, the
vast majority of it, in fact,
and the majority of that
is spent on civil defense,
although I have spent
a fair amount of time
doing civil plaintiff work as well.
I was definitely prepared
coming out of law school
to represent someone who was a bad guy,
or more likely someone who was wrong.
What I found actually is
that in every single case
I ever had, all of my clients,
and really if I'm fair,
the other people that we were up against,
had colorable legal arguments.
If you file a lawsuit or
where you have to deal with
a lawsuit or you're
getting into litigation,
odds are the case is
somewhere on the margins,
such that each side is going
to have reasonable arguments.
And when you have reasonable arguments,
it's easy to see why your
client should win the case.
Now, sometimes those legal arguments
are more of a technicality.
Frankly, if a client was
clearly in the wrong,
then often it's the role
of the lawyer to tell them
that they should not fight
this particular case.
Often that's why the
vast majority of cases
actually settle out of court.
So if there was a rare instance
where I didn't feel like
the client had a leg to stand on,
then almost certainly that
client would have settled
and gotten out of the lawsuit that way.
If you get into multimillion
dollar litigation
and you keep going forward
and you get to trial,
the reason that you're in trial is
because both sides think they can win.
So that's actually the rarity,
to actually get that far into a case.
For the most part, if
people did something wrong,
they're going to settle
and try and get out
as quickly as possible.
Sergei Niskanen says, "how
can one become a judge?
Are there some special
law schools for that?
Or is it more a question
of long-term legal practice
and general experience, or maybe there are
some very specific requirements.
Have you ever considered a
judicial career for yourself?"
So how you become a judge?
Well, that depends on the jurisdiction.
Some are appointed by the
governor or the president,
and some are elected,
depends on where you live
and the particular court
you're dealing with.
No special law schools,
any law school will do,
though going to a higher ranked law school
makes you more likely to become a judge,
I would probably say.
Though, when you are
appointed to be a judge,
often certain states
and the federal system
will send you to judge
school because often
people don't know what they're doing
and it's sort of a crash course
and actually being a judge.
So technically there is sort
of a special judge school,
and I have absolutely no aspirations
of becoming a judge myself.
I am very, very thankful that
we have a lot of good judges
out there, but that is
definitely not something
I would want to do myself.
All right, let's do some
rapid fire questions.
I think I've been taking
this way too seriously,
and I want to get through a
bunch more of these questions.
So let's try and do it.
Christopher Miller asks,
"when did it become comfortable
speaking in front of a judge?"
I have never had a problem
speaking in front of a judge.
I think that dates back to
doing speech and debate in high
school, and actually
frankly in middle school
and maybe elementary school,
I did a bunch of speech competition.
So I have always been very,
very comfortable speaking
in front of a crowd.
And you know, a judge
is just like a crowd,
but it's one person and
they're very, very powerful.
Okay. Zane Woollett asks
"when can I get a t-shirt
that says the bailiff will tackle you?"
I don't know, I'm not
totally sold on merch yet.
Maybe some day, let me
know if you guys want that,
or like tie clips or,
I'm very particular about
a very special kind of legal pad,
so if you guys would want
Legal Eagle legal pads,
let me know, maybe merch is in the future,
I could definitely make that happen.
Kalp Shah asks, "why
did you become a lawyer
and then stop to do YouTube?
Seems to me a lawyer
would be an easier job."
Well, I haven't stopped being a lawyer.
I still practice all the time,
though YouTube is definitely
taking up a larger and larger
portion of my day to day life,
which is awesome because YouTube
is really, really creative.
Who gets to make creative
video essays all day long?
You know, being a lawyer
is great, I love it.
I always wanted to be a lawyer, but also,
the deadlines are
terrible in the sense that
sometimes if you you miss a deadline,
your client is screwed, and
to live under the Damocles of
these looming deadlines,
man, that is no fun.
At least in YouTube, if
you miss a video by a day
is not jurisdictional and you
get kicked off of YouTube.
That can happen in real life as a lawyer.
So, you know, YouTube is
fun. Tri Monster asks,
"What is a part of your
job that people typically
don't realize lawyers do?"
I would say probably
telling them not to sue,
or that a lawsuit is not
in their best interest,
or telling them that they don't want me to
actually go forward and be
as aggressive as possible.
A lot of people see lawyers
on TV and they assume that
the best thing to do is always sue
and to always be incredibly aggressive.
That's actually rarely the case,
and sometimes something
is not worth suing over.
You might have been wronged,
but it's not worth it to
spend tens of thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands
of dollars on attorneys.
Sometimes there are amicable
ways of settling things
that are actually net
positives for both sides.
And so a lot of them lawyer's
job is not just as a zealous
advocate, but also as a business
person to help two sides
come together to find a
mutually amicable solution.
Let's see, Jonathan Chang asks,
"when you doing the collab with Dr. Mike?"
When Dr. Mike responds.
If I need to stand
outside of his apartment
with a boombox over my
head like John Cusack
to make that happen, I
will totally do that.
Dr. Mike is awesome.
You should definitely watch his channel,
and I hope someday we get to collaborate.
Courage Gallegos asks,
"are you a Sith Lord?"
Wouldn't you like to know?
All right, Susanna asks,
"I am a high school
student and have considered
becoming a lawyer, but I'm unsure.
What are some ways I can
know if being a lawyer
is the right career I should go into?"
Well, a couple of things.
Number one, you can do mock trial in high.
I did a mock trial all
throughout high school,
college and law school.
While it's not the greatest representation
of the day to day life of a lawyer,
it will give you a taste for litigation
and it will make you a
better public speaker,
and it will help you think on your feet.
In addition to that, pay
attention in English class.
What lawyers really do every day is write.
They write and write and write.
They'll do some research and
then they'll write some more.
And so being a lawyer is more
about being a great writer
than it is being a great public
speaker, generally speaking.
If that appeals to you, then law school
might be the way to go.
Pedro4816 asks, "Are you going
to read all of the comments,
including this one?" Yes.
Idoit asks "since you've looked
at a lot of legal movies,
what do you think makes
a legal movie enjoyable
while still being accurate?"
While I am happy to criticize legal movies
for their accuracy, legal accuracy is not
the most important thing for me
when I'm watching a legal movie,
I think the dialogue needs to
be good, and most importantly,
the characters need to grow.
Basically everything
that happens in the plot
is really just in service
of helping the protagonist
or the antagonist grow as a person,
and that I think is the
most important thing.
Sometimes legal accuracy
totally gets in the way of that,
but sometimes you'll get a
show like Better Call Saul
that is able to tell amazing stories
while still being legally accurate,
and that's super cool too.
CoolGuyNotFoolGuy asked "stupid question,
but why did you choose
the name Legal Eagle?"
Because Eagles are cool and it rhymes.
And as one of the comments pointed out,
unlawful falafel doesn't
have the same ring to it.
Okay, Edward Zhang asks
"to add to the question
of your specialty in
law, what made you decide
on this particular specialty?
I'm a prospective law student
and having a hard time
figuring out what I
want to specialize in."
Well, in a way, I haven't
really specialized.
I am a litigator and trial lawyer,
so I guess my specialty is the process,
the process of the lawsuit,
the process of going to trial,
but in terms of the substantive
law that I deal with,
it has varied widely.
It includes copywriting,
includes class action defense,
it includes contracts,
business, IP, banking,
and it's great that every
day I get to research
something new, it keeps things fresh.
And that's one of the things
I love about this particular
channel is that I get to do research into
new parts of the law to
become a momentary expert
about these particular
things so that I can explain
the law to other people.
So in some ways, I
haven't had to specialize,
and that's one of the
things that I think is great
about being a litigator
and/or a trial lawyer,
Bren S asks, "What was your
proudest moment as a lawyer?"
There was one case
where I was dealing with
the worst opposing counsel
I have ever dealt with in my entire life.
Just the biggest jerk I've
ever had the misfortune
to go up against, and when I
beat the pants off of that guy,
I was really, really happy about that
because he deserved to lose
and he deserved to get
smacked down by the court.
If I remember correctly, he
was sanctioned by the court,
which doesn't happen all that often.
It's a little petty, but
man, not going to deny,
it felt really, really good.
Olivia KOREVAAR asks, "what is
an important thing about law
you wish everyone understood?"
This is going to sound
strange coming from a lawyer,
but just because something
is legal or illegal,
doesn't mean it's morally
right or morally wrong,
which is one of the reasons why law
is so bound up in politics.
The end result of politics is law.
We always have to stay
vigilant to make sure that
our laws reflect our society and justice.
Okay. Jonathan Chang asks,
"How old are you, man?
I've always wondered that."
I am 36. Thank you for asking.
Valerio asks "if you
hadn't become a lawyer,
what other profession/job
would you have had
or like to do?"
Before I wanted to be a lawyer,
there was a very brief amount of time
where I wanted to be an architect.
In my spare time, I often do
a bunch of home renovations.
I really like the idea of
playing with space and, you know,
making your home nicer. So I
think if I wasn't a lawyer,
I'd probably be architect or a contractor
doing renovation stuff, which
is kind of a hobby of mine.
And finally I_pancake asks "what
led you to doing YouTube in
addition to being a lawyer?" Funny story.
So when I was in high school,
my senior English teacher
gave us the option to either
write an essay or to do a final
project as a video project.
Well, hello there, I'm Devin Stone.
me and my three best friends
thought writing an essay
was sounded terrible.
So we decided to do this
video project that turned into
this huge thing that became an hour long,
where we satirized every
piece of English literature
that we read that year in class.
Sorry, sweetheart.
I have another mistress.
(scoffs)
Her name is justice.
I'm actually still really proud of this.
We did Macbeth as celebrity Jeopardy.
Once again, his is Alex
Trebek for Celebrity Jeopardy
saying good night, good night.
(dramatic music)
we Did Jane Austen's Pride
and Prejudice as a soap opera
called The Proud and The Prejudiced.
I think it's still really good.
So that really got me
interested in video editing,
and I didn't really pick it
up again until much later.
I wanted to start a channel
where I helped law students
get through law school,
because I had a really
good time in law school,
I thought it was really fun,
and it had a lot of tips
and tricks for people to
do well in law school.
So I started Legal Eagle as a way to help
current and future law students,
and that sort of snowballed
into what you see today,
where I expanded it not just
to tips about law school,
but just explaining the law in general.
So that's how I got started with YouTube.
It's been a crazy ride and I
guess I might as well tell you
what's next for the channel.
For the near future, we're
going to be doubling down.
There are so many legal issues
that we have to discuss,
so many things that happen in the news,
and I would really like to
be able to do more videos.
Over the last few months,
given that everyone has been
sort of confined to their house,
I've been able to find some
time and get more videos out,
which has helped the channel grow,
and I would like to be able to
do that on a permanent basis.
If not two videos a week,
then perhaps three videos every two weeks,
I'd like to expand out
different formats of videos.
I have a bunch of ideas
of things that are related
to the channel, but I haven't
been able to touch on yet,
maybe some more humorous content.
And if you have ideas
about how you'd like to see
that expansion going, I'm all ears.
And like I said, it's so much fun
to be able to do these
videos, and it's so rewarding
to know that that some people
find this information valuable.
Of course, people ask
me how I have the time
to be able to do these things.
And the answer is because
I drink a lot of coffee
and consume a lot of caffeine,
which is why I'm so thrilled
that Trade Coffee is the
sponsor of today's video.
These days, I am basically
fueled by coffee and rage.
Trade Coffee in particular is great
because not only do they
have a huge selection
of your favorite coffees,
but they have an awesome quiz
to get matched to coffee recommendations
based on your taste preferences.
I myself like a sweeter, full
bodied, chocolaty coffee.
And while I don't drink coffee every day,
mainly on days when I have
to film hours and hours
worth of videos, I want my
coffee to actually taste good.
And with Trade, you can
discover new coffees
from the nation's best coffee roasters,
and Trade matches you to
your own personal selection
of coffee and conveniently
delivers it straight to you.
So you don't have to leave the house
to go into a supermarket.
There might be reasons why
you might not want to do that
under the circumstances.
So Trade will get you the
best coffees at the best price
and deliver them straight to your door.
The first 100 Legal
Eagles will get 30% off
their first bag when they sign
up and you get free shipping.
So just click on the
link in the description,
take the coffee quiz at Trade Coffee,
and choose your frequency,
whether you want one
bag or a subscription,
and then rate your coffee
so your suggestions will get even better.
You can even choose whole
beans or your preferred grind.
It really is the best
coffee website out there.
So to get 30% off of your
first order at Trade Coffee,
click on the link in the description,
or use the promo code
legal 30 at checkout.
Clicking on that link really
helps out this channel.
So thank you for sticking with me.
If you want to see some
more videos of mine,
click over here, I've got a
whole bunch of legal reactions,
explaining legal things in the news.
So click on this playlist.
I'll see you in court
and thanks a million.